اذا مشاهدينا كما نتابع من خلال هذه الصور
التي وردتنا الان صور خاصه للعربيه مقابر
جماعيه فيها تاي تحوي على اكثر من خمسه
الاف جثه كما نشاهد
اذا بسبب العدد الكبير لضحايا هذا الزلزال
والذي كما ذكرنا في بدايه هذه النشره في
تركيا وحدها وصل الى 25 الف قتيل عدا عدد
المصابين اكثر من 80 الف لجا
المنقذون والدفاع المدني لدفن الضحايا في
مدافن جماعيه هنا هذه المدفنه فيها طاي
وهذه المنطقه
مقابر جماعيه هنا وتحمل الشواهد ارقاما
وليس اسماء
اذا مشاهدينا كما نشاهد على الشواهد ارقام
لمقبره جماعيه دفن فيها اكثر من 5000 شخص
من ضحايا الزلزال جراء الاعداد الكبيره
يبدو ان المقابر لم تعد الطبيعيه تتسع
لضحايا الزلزال في ظل الارقام الهائله
التي من المتوقع ان تتضاعف وذلك بحسب
تصريحات للامم المتحده وحتى تصريحات تركيه
خاصه في ظل وجود من هم لا زالوا تحت
الانقاذ حتى الان لازالت الامال في اخراج
عدد من الاحياء خاصه بعد ان تم انتشار
البعض رغم مرور سبعه ايام على هذه الكارثه
الانسانيه ولكن رغم ذلك لا شك بانه
الاعداد الجثث ايضا
بالمئات ان لم تكن بالالاف اعود اليك